what do this and this and this which
apparently is called orange justice have
in common with this the answer for not
the game that is bad a wave of dance
crazes and supercharged the viral growth
of live streaming platform twitch which
has just opened a European HQ in
London's West End our audience is
growing and every geography that we
operate in you know we're seeing just
incredible year-on-year growth we have
over 100 million people globally who
watch twitch and 15 million people daily
who tuned in to watch twitch and we have
at least a million people at any point
of time on twitch thanks to events like
this one with England footballer dolly
Ally twitches viewership in the UK is up
50 percent year-on-year
but success brings tough questions about
is twitch doing enough to protect
youngest users we are actually investing
very strongly to ensure that we have
robust guidelines around the content
that we have on our service and it's a
perpetual investment for us we're not
only our investing and technology tools
to do that
but we also have moderators who can
investigate any reports of concerns
about contact so simply put you're not
worried about people spending too much
time on twitch I think the engagement on
twitch is an engagement with a community
being concerned about people spending
time would be like saying are you
concerned about people spending time
with a group of friends not everyone
agrees including the NSPCC associate
head of Child Safety online on a site
like twitch children can live stream
they can live broadcast themselves or
they can chat with any other user on the
platform now children have told us that
if a child has live streamed one in 20
of those have had a request to undress
on camera so we're talking about really
unpleasant requests being made a
significant numbers of children for
parents even have children too young for
the big kids game it's a worry kids are
becoming much more internet savvy and
you want to take those precautions and
safeguards to the sort of bad element
but you've got to compromise which is
the rationale for this had inspired
dance class with all the best fiction
moves because all dogs can learn my
tricks just not in this case Ron a man
thought Sky News